SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND
WELCOME. TO OUR FIRST HEARING OF
THIS SECOND YEAR OF A TWO YEAR
SESSION OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IN
HERE TO A SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE.
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND-
THERE ARE NO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY. I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO BE PRESENT IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
OUR CORPSMAN BEGINNER HEARING TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS. WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. CRAWL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEES
WEBSITES WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN WHEN I WENT OUT TO
TODAY. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
I'LL SAY THAT AGAIN EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO EIGHT
THREE. THE AND HE ACCESS CODE
IS THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO
EIGHT THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE ISTOM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITES. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. S. THIS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THERE MAY BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN A
QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU
WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND- THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AGAIN ONCE YOU'RE CALLED
ON MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING US ON. ALL THE
OBVIOUSLY ON MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. IS ALSO A GOOD
TIME TO REMIND EVERYONE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT THIS IS
A FISCAL COMMITTEE SO PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO THE
FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL. THAT
YOU'RE TESTIFYING PLEASE REFRAIN
FROM REPEATING PRIOR TESTIMONY
AND RE LITIGATING THE POLICY
MERITS OF A BILL FOCUSED ON THE
FISCAL IMPLICATIONS. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT
SO THAT ALL INTERESTED PARTIES
CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE EIGHTEEN
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. ONE OF
WHICH IS ELIGIBLE FOR A DO PASS
THE REST OF THE BILLS ARE ALL
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
INFORMED US THAT THEY WILL NOT
BE PARTICIPATING IN THIS HEARING
TODAY. THEY HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON
THE RELEASE OF THE STATE BUDGET
. IT IS UNLIKELY THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE FILES FOR THE BILLS BEFORE
US TODAY. BEFORE WE HEAR
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR PORTANTINO I AM
HERE PORTANTINO HERE SENATOR
BATES SENATOR BRADFORD YOUR
CENTER BRADFORD HERE SENATOR
JONES. UNDER KAMLAGER CARE
CENTER KAMLAGER HERE CENTER
LAYERED YEAH THEY'RE LAYERED
HERE CENTER BY CAL SKI HERE MY
COUNTY HERE WE HAVE FIVE MEMBERS
PRESENT. WE HAVE A QUORUM AND
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
BUSINESS OF THE DAY DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF THE HEARING. PSYCHOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS ABI INSTITUTING A TIME
LIMIT ON WITNESS TESTIMONY EACH
SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED THREE
MINUTES OF TOTAL TIME FOR
PRIMARY TESTIMONY. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME.
ORGANIZATION AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE IF
NECESSARY WILL ALSO LIMIT THIS
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY. TO TWELVE
MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE AS A
REMINDER ALL WITNESSES SHOULD
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE
FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL-
WE'RE GONNA STATE STREET TO THE
ME TOO PART OF THE HEARING SO
EVERYBODY PAY ATTENTION. OUR
FIRST BILL UP IS S. B. THREE. BY
SENATOR KABIRU EDUCATE DUCATION
FINANCE- THE SENATOR HAS WAITED
TO SUSPEND CANDIDATE THE OTHERS
WAY PRESENTATION SO WE'LL MOVE
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE.
SEEING NO ONE HERE IN SUPPORT WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THOSE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE.
AND CALL THEM FORWARD
INDIVIDUALLY. AND LEADING GERMAN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IN ONE ZERO CHORE IN
SUPPORT. TALKING POINTS FROM
YOUR STAFF UPGRADE THANKS. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NONE IN OUR
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE NOBODY
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO OPPOSITION
OTHER ANY WITNESSES IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE OPPOSED SB THREE.
SEEING NO ONE RUSHED TO THE
MICROPHONE WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
CONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT ANYONE OPPOSED SB THREE
AND CALL THEM FORWARD. AND IF
YOU'RE NOW IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN
ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT THE
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN
OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE GONE UP SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND AS WE KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
PARTICIPATING TODAY SO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON SB
THREE. SINGLE SINGLE HANDS GO UP
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE IS
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE. FILE
MOVING ON TO SB FORTY FIVE BY
PORTANTINO. ON CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS ORGANIC WASTE
REDUCTION GOALS- OBVIOUSLY OF
WAVE PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONIES OR ANYONE
HERE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT OF
SB FORTY FIVE SEEING NO ONE.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY FIVE. IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. BEEN ONE
ZERO FOR SUPPORT FOR THE S. B.
FORTY FIVE. THIS TIME WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE ALL
RIGHT MOVING ON TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED SB FORTY FIVE.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB FORTY FIVE
. FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT HAVE AN
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND HAVING NO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FORTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPECTSMOVING ON S. THREE
THIRTY ALSO BY ME- THIS IS ON
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD- CONSTITUENTS OF EMERGING
CONCERN. IN DRINKING WATER- SB
TWO THIRTY. FIVE WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE'LL GO RIGHT
TO TESTIMONY AND SUPPORTERS OR
ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE OF
SUPPORT SEEING NO ONE RUSH THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR WILL GO TO
THE- CONFERENCE LINE IS THERE
ANY SUPPORT FOR SB TWO THIRTY.
AND THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
THAT'S HOW WE DO HAVE ONE IN OUR
QUEUE TO BE JUST A MOMENT.
YEAH
WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GOOD MORNING ALL PETER BORDER
WITH MIKE- THE VALLEY INDUSTRY
AND COMMERCE ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO THIRTY.
THANKS. AT THE TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION IT
WILL COME BACK TO ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE THERE'S NO ONE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE RUSHING TO PROPOSE
SB TWO THIRTY. SO WE'LL GO TO
THE- CONFERENCE LINE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE CUED UP WHO IS OPPOSED
SB TWO THIRTY. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO AT THE TWO THIRTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THE
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
FROM MY COLLEAGUES. WITHOUT
OPPOSITION S. B. TWO THIRTY WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN BY PORTANTINO
PEOPLE HEALTH SCHOOL EMPLOYMENT
PEOPLE TRAINING YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE I'VE WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE'LL MOVE
RIGHT INTO SUPPORT. FOR SB FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE'S NO ONE
FACTION ME IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NO ONE HERE
RUSSIAN IN THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. FOR SUPPORT
FOR SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. IT'LL
BE JUST A MOMENT. MARK NEVER
MIND. WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIGN IN THE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL A
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCY
SUPPORT ALSO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA. ACCESS COALITION IN
SUPPORT. AT THE TIME- WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOT OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE RUSSIAN IN
THE MICROPHONE MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. NOT
POSITION TO SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. BUT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN OUR
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WE WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MR CASSIE
NO FALSE FALSE HAND UP. HI THIS
IS. I WAS LOOKING AT THE
APPROVED OF PANTS FELL ON THE
TEMPER VERSUS OF LOS. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTION WITHOUT
A- SPC EIGHTY SEVEN. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE PORTANTINO INCOME
TAXES MOTION PICTURE. TAX CREDIT
EXTEND. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE FIVE WAY PRESENTATION.
SO WE WILL MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY MISTER MCKINLEY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
CHRIS MAKAYLA ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU THANK YOU SEEING
NO ONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM COME TO
THE MICROPHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY FIVE. MODERATE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE PLEASE KEEP UP
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF FOUR EIGHT
FIVE. SAM FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THE NOW WE DO
HAVE TO IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL GO
TO LINE IT SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON PETER WARD
UP WITH LIKE AT THE VALLEY
INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION AND WE SUPPORT SB
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. WELL
NOW GO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE MONEY GONNA BE AT
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. I DID HAVE
ANOTHER JOIN OUR QUEUE- WILL GO
TO FIND SEVENTEEN LINE SEVENTEEN
PLEASEGO AHEAD. A LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT
ON MUTE. POLICIES HI THIS IS
CATHY GARNER G. SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
OUT TO COUNSEL AND THE
ENTERTAINMENT UNION COALITION
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOT OPPOSITION-
THE SEARS NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
RUSHING TO THE MICROPHONE. TO
OPPOSE FORTY FIVE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB FORTY FIVE. AND FOR THOSE I
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF FORTY
FIVE AND SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MISTER
Y. CALCULAR MCPHILLIPS IS B. DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
VICTIMS COMPENSATION FUND I'M
GONNA GO. OUT THERE AND CONNECT
WITH YOUR MIND PRESIDING. NOT
LONG THIS IS A SB SIX THREE TWO
PORTANTINO ON CALIFORNIA VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD. WHICH IS
ELIGIBLE FOR TO PASS A MOTION-
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU ARE
COLLEAGUES- THIS BILL WOULD
APPROPRIATE APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD FOR THE
PAYMENT OF TWO STATE CLAIMS
RELATED TO A RONI IS CONVICTION
OF GEORGE SALUTIS AND GUY MILES
IN EACH OF THE RUNNERS
CONVICTION CASES THE COURT SET
ASIDE THE CONVICTIONS AND
GRANTED HABEAS RELIEF THE BOARD
IS FOUND THAT THEY ARE BOTH.
DEMONSTRATE BY A PREPONDERANCE
OF EVIDENCE THAT THEY WERE
INNOCENT AND RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED AN
APPROPRIATION TO COVER THE
PAYMENTS I HAVE NEIL ANNIS FROM
THE VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD
HERE ON THE COAST LINE. AS A
SUPPORT WITNESS HE'S AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE AROUND HIS
CONVICTION CLAIMS. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND OBVIOUSLY AT THE
PERFECT TIME WOULD ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MR IN A SISTER
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE CATFISH SEE
NO QUESTIONS FOR MY COLLEAGUES
APPEAR. ANYTHING WANT TO ADD TO
THE PRESENTATION. A GOOD MORNING
AND ILLNESS OF THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD- NO I'M JUST
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY IS THERE ANYBODY HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OF THE THREE D.
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. S. SIX THREE TWO WE SEE
NONE. LET'S NOW MOVE TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WAITING TESTIFYING
SUPPORT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR YOU PLEASE PROMPT-
THOSE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX THREE TWO AND
CALL THEM FORWARD. AND FOR THOSE
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
THREE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
. AND ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN OUR QUEUE LET'S FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCEDURE FOR ANY
OPPOSITION IS OR ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
TOURISTS WHO WHICH TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. SIX THREE
TWO. SEEING NONE MODERATOR WORK-
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL ANY
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
OUR TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. IN
OPPOSITION SB SIX THREE TWO. AND
FOR THOSE THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX THREE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AT THE TIME WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE THANK
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS MISTER CHURCHES LIKE
TO CLOSE. THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER CHAIRMAN
THE BILL THERE'S A MOTION BY
CENTER LAYERED- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WITH A DO PASS REFER TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. PARDON ME-
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATE BILL SIX THREE TWO
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO OUR
FATES BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. CENTER KAMLAGER
HI KAMLAGER I'D LAYERED ON A
LAYERED BY. BURKE OWSKI HI MY
COUNTY FIVE LET'S KEEP THIS ROLE
OPEN FOR THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS IT
DOES APPEAR TO HAVE SUFFICIENT
VOTES TO- MOVE FORWARD. FIVE
ZERO. THANK YOU MISTER Y. CASKEY
WE WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT.
AUTHOR WHICH IS SENATOR WIENER.
WE HOLD THE KEY. S. B. TWO
SEVENTY ONE- SENATOR WIENER ON
JURIES- JUST AUTHORS WAVED
PRESENTATION IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES- MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
SUPPORT TWENTY ONE AND FORTY TWO
OR THREE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
SEVEN ONE SINGLE INCOME TO
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE GO
OF ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN ONE. FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT
THE TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
COMPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE COMING IN
THE MICROPHONE TO OPPOSE. SB TWO
SEVEN ONCE A MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED S. B. TWO SEVEN ONE
. OTHER THAN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
TWO SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THE TIME WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
TO THE SP TWO SEVENTY ONE. I SEE
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO SEVEN
ONE. WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVIE
ON SB THREE SEVEN NINE BY
SENATOR WIENER ON RESIDENTIAL
SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEM PERMITTING.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION A MOVE
RIGHT PUBLIC TESTIMONY. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM RUSHING TO
THE MICROPHONE ON THREE SEVEN
NINE. MODERATOR PLEASE GO OF
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVEN NINE. FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF IT B THREE SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUEUEING UP IT'LL BE JUST
A MOMENT.
WELL FIRST GO TO LINE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER
ELEVEN PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT ON
MUTE. HELLO LINE ELEVEN YOUR
LINES OPEN. IT IS IT'S MY LIFE.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU WELL I WOULD
NEVER FIND A NUMBER SORRY THIS
IS THE ONLY GATHERED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND WILL NOW GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
CATHERINE WITH THE NOVA ENERGY
CORPORATION CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SEVENTY NINE THANK
YOU. AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT
HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORT WILL
GO NOW TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
RUSHING IN THE MICROPHONE.
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE OF ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE WHO IS OPPOSED
SB THREE SEVEN NINE. M. FOR
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THE TIME WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES WITH THEIR HANDS GO
UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
SEVEN NINE WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON AS THREE FOUR SIX
SEVEN. BY SENATOR WIENER ON
TRIAL TESTIMONY EXPERT WITNESSES
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO AGO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
RUSSIAN TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED PUSHING ME
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIX SEVEN.
BUT FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR SIX SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE COMING IN THE
MICROPHONE TO OPPOSE FOUR SIX
SEVEN. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED US BEFORE
SIX SEVEN. AND FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR SIX SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN
OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT HAVEN'T
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION FOR SIX
SEVEN AND SEEING NO HANDS OF MY
COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT A
POSITION. AS BEFORE SIX SEVEN
WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
MOVING ON S. B. TWO EIGHTY SIX
BY SENATOR MEN ON ELECTIONS FOR
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OPPOSITE WAY
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE EAST
RUSSIAN THE MICROPHONE TO
SUPPORT. SB TWO EIGHTY SIX
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IS SUPPORT OF SB TWO EIGHT
SIX. FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWO EIGHT SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AT THE TIME WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
EIGHTY SIX THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE OPPOSED TO SB
TWO EIGHTY SIX BINARIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPPOSED SB TWO EIGHT SIX. THOSE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWO EIGHT
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE- SOMEONE QUEUING UP IT'LL
BE JUST A MOMENT. AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS- DR DAVID PATTERSON
I'M A TRUSTEE ON THE PLASTER
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION AND
I'M OPPOSED TO- THE S. B. TWO
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY ELSE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT HAVEN'T TAKEN IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
EIGHTY SIX AND SEEING NO HANDS
OF MY COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB TWO EIGHTY SIX
DOUBLE FOR THE SUSPENSE FILE.
LEON TO SENATOR SKINNER HAS TWO
BILLS STARTING WITH SB THREE OH
ONE ON ONLINE ON THE ONLINE
MARKETPLACE. THE SENATORS WAVE
TO PRESENTATION THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES TO MOVE
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT. THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
COMING IN THE MICROPHONE TO
SUPPORT THREE OH ONE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE OH ONE.
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE OH
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED SB THREE OH
ONE. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB THREE OH
ONE. FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE A ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE OH
ONE WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. BILLION SB SIX FORTY ONE
BY SENATOR SKINNER ON CALFRESH
COLLEGE STUDENTS ACT. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT
INTO PUBLIC TESTIMONY. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SIX FORTY ONE. MODERATOR'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FOUR ONE. BUT
FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FOUR ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE IN OUR QUEUE
TO JUST BE A MOMENT.
THEN WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
MY NAME'S JASIM PRASAD THE VICE-PRESIDENT LEGISLATORS TO THE
INTERNET THE CALIFORNIA CAN
COLLEGES AND WE ARE IN HIGH
SUPPORT AND SB SIX FORTY ONE
THANK YOU. SIX WILL BE LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ALEX PEOPLE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA KID NAY
COMMISSION AND STRONG SUPPORT SB
SIX TWENTY ONE THANK. BUT I WANT
TO GO. MY BODY. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT LET'S
GO TO OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO SIX FORTY
ONE SEEING NO ONE. IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB SIX FORTY ONE. FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX FOUR ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT HAVE A TICKET SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ENCINO QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SIX FOUR ONE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. PUTTING ON TO
SENATOR HERTZBERG'S TO BILLS
STARTING WITH SB THREE SEVEN
SEVEN ON RADIOLOGY ASSISTANCE
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO MOVE
RIGHT PUBLIC TESTIMONY. ANYONE
WISHING TO SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THREE SEVEN SEVEN. THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVEN SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE WITHOUT OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE SEVEN SEVEN THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
MODERATORS RUNNING FOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB THREE
SEVEN SEVEN. AND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THREE SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE
DO HAVE SOMEONE CHEWING UP IT'LL
BE JUST A MOMENT. THEN WE'LL GO
TO LINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TERRIFYING TO COPY IN
YOUR LOCAL STATION WE'RE OPPOSED
TO THREE- SB THREE SEVEN SEVEN
WHICH WOULD INTRODUCE AN
ADDITIONAL PRACTITIONER TO
PROVIDE CARE FOR RADIOLOGY
PATIENTS THEREBY FURTHER
FRAGMENTING THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE. IN REGARDS TO CALL
WHENEVER A NEW CATEGORY FOR
HUMANE ARTSPRACTITIONERS IS
ESTABLISHED COSTS GO UP IN THE
STATE IN WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM- JIM MAY INCLUDE
PROMULGATION OF NEW RAGS AND THE
COST OF OVERSEEING THE NEW
PRACTITIONER OVERALL THIS TYPE
OF PREGNANT TO TAKING UP SHARES
ALSO SHE WOULD BE INCREASE
PROPER CARE A HIGHER CHANCE OF
HAVING A DEPARTURE FROM CLINICAL
BEST PRACTICE. AND HIGHER RATES
OF UP IN THE HOSPITALIZATIONS
ACCORDING WE ASK FOR YOUR.
MOBILE TODAY THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME HAVE NO OTHERS OUR QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'VE TAKEN FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION SEEING A QUESTIONS
FOR MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE SEVEN SEVEN
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
SB FIVE THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. ON HOMELESS SHELTER
GRANTS FOR PETS AND VETERINARY
SERVICES IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION. MOVE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT SAYING NO ONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE SUPPORTIVE OF SB FIVE
THIRTEEN. IN THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. OKAY WE DO HAVE A WE
HAVE THREE IN OUR QUEUE AT THE
MOMENT. WE'LL START WITH LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
TERRY BECAUSE ROSS BUCKLEY I'M
OF YOUR TECHNICAL SUPPORT. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ELIZABETH ORRICK ON BEHALF OF
BEST FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH. ACTUALLY. FIVE THIRTEEN. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MATA GONNA BE HAPPY THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S GOOD OPPOSITION
OF SB. FIVE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB FIVE THIRTEEN. FOR
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT WE TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE THIRTEEN I SEE NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
THIRTEEN WILL MOVE. TO SUSPEND.
SERVING THE SENATOR CORTESE HAS
THIS BEFORE THIRTY FIVE ON CIVIL
LAW. PERSONAL RIGHTS ONLINE SEX
TRAFFICKING- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION. SOMEONE MOVE RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE. MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
S. BEFORE THIRTY FIVE. LOWS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN
OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR THIRTY
FIVE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED US BEFORE
THIRTY FIVE. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. FOR THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN OUR
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR THIRTY
FIVE. C. NO HANDS GO UP FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION AS
BEFORE THIRTY FIVE WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. CENTER ALLEN HAS TWO
BILLS BEFORE US STARTING WITH SB
FIVE SEVENTY NINE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE- THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT- THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE SEVENTY NINE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SEVEN NINE.
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS
IN OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SEVEN
NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE COMING IN THE
MICROPHONE TO OPPOSE MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB FIVE SEVEN NINE. AND FOR
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE BEEN DONE
IN OUR QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE SEVEN NINE I SEE NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
SEVEN NINE WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPEND FILE. SB SIX TWENTY ON
DISTILLED SPIRITS. X. SHIPPING
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO GO
RIGHT TO. OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE COMING TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX TWENTY. M. FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND AS OF NOW WE
DO HAVE FOR IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL
START WITH LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JERRY MEMBERS
MAKES ALL OF ON BEHALF OF THE A
CALIFORNIA ARTISANAL DISTILLERS
GUILD REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY CRAFT DISTILLERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
JUST TO KNOW THAT WE CURRENTLY
ARE ABLE TO SHIP DIRECT TO
CONSUMERS WITH WITH NO LIMITS
AND THAT'S BEEN A LIFELINE FOR
THESE CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES.
THAT ABILITY ENDS AT THE END OF
MARCH SO THIS BILL IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO THAT WERE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO SHIP TO OUR
CUSTOMERS IN THE STATE AND IT'S
A LIFELINE TO SMALL BUSINESSES
IN IT THAT IS NOT EXTENDED OR
THE BILL DOES NOT PASS WE'RE
GOING BE FACING LAYOFFS AND
BUSINESS IS CLOSING IN
CALIFORNIA APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MELISSA HI DO I'M BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WINEMAKERS THAT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE LINE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A LINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT ON
MUTE. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS KEVIN MCCUE ON BEHALF OF
THE DISTILLED SPIRITS COUNCIL WE
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU'RE SURE OF
NUMBERS THIS IS CHRIS WALKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CRAFT
BREWERS ASSOCIATION SB SIX
TWENTY WILL HARMONIZE STATE LAW
THE FEDERAL TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S BEER INDUSTRIES
DECADES LONG ABILITY TO SEND
BEER TO CUSTOMERS THE COMMON
CARRIERS. SB SIX TWENTY PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S PROUD BEER INDUSTRY
ITS CUSTOMERS AND THOUSANDS OF
LOCAL JOBS FROM POTENTIAL HARM
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THIS
INDUSTRY ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT THAT WAS OUR SECOND
PRIME WITNESS EVERYONE OF YOU
COULD COMBINE TO MEET TO
TESTIMONY THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
AT THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
TWENTY. SIR ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
NO WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
SINCE NO ONE IS HERE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION IN PERSON
MODERATORS OR ANYONE OPPOSED SB
SIX TWENTY ON THE PHONE LINE.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION SB SIX
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AS
OF NOW THERE ARE TWO IN OUR
QUEUE IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT. IT
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE
MEMBERS MATT BROAD ON BEHALF OF
THE TEAMSTERS- IN OPPOSITION WE
JUST WANTED TO WEIGH IN AND SAY
WE ARE STILL OPPOSED THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHANNEL SLIPPER THE
CALIFORNIA BEER AND BEVERAGE
DISTRIBUTORS WE ROOM REMAIN
OPPOSED WE DON'T THINK THAT THIS
COULD OPEN UP BOB CALIFORNIA
TRAVIS STREET- TRIPPING. ONCE
AGAIN WORK POST THANK YOU. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD
FROM THE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AGAIN THIS BILL WILL BE GOING TO
SUSPENSE SEEING NO QUESTIONS.
HAVE A QUESTION I DO MISTER
CHAIR CURRENT OKAY I WAS JUST.
WONDERING GIVEN THE FACT THAT I
WAS IN- GEO WHEN THIS BILL WAS
HEARD AND LOOKING AT THE
ANALYSIS THAT'S IN OUR BINDERS
NOW IT IS STRIKINGLY SIMILAR TO
THE ANALYSIS THAT WAS IN. G. O.
EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS
SUBSTANTIVE DISCUSSION AND A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED THAT WOULD HAVE A FISCAL
IMPACT ON THE BILL. AND YET
THOSE. COMMENTS OR POINTS WERE
NOT REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS SO
AS A TO THE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION FOR ME- ARM. GIVEN
I KNOW THIS IS JUST TO PUT IT ON
SUSPENSE BEFORE IT GOES BEFORE
US AGAIN THE REASON WHY SOME OF
THAT WAS NOT CAPTURED AS IT
PROBABLY WILL HELP- IN
CONTEXTUALIZING. WHAT WE MAY END
UP SEEING. THE QUESTION IS A
GOOD QUESTION THE ANSWER IS THAT
THE PARTIES ARE STILL TALKING TO
EACH OTHER AND HAVE NOT COME TO
AN AGREEMENT ON THOSE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES SO THE
ANALYSIS REFLECTS THE BILL AS-
IN PRINT DOES NOT REFLECT THE
ONGOING NATURE OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
NOT. BEEN SUBMITTED YET. OKAY SO
MY ASSUMPTION IS THAT BOY THAT'S
WHEN WE SEE THIS BILL AGAIN IF
IN FACT THERE ARE. NEGOTIATIONS
THAT HAPPEN WHERE ALL PARTIES
ARE IN AGREEMENT OR NOT BUT WHAT
THE AUTHOR DECIDES THAT WILL BE
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT'LL BE BEFORE. FOR THE VOTE
. THE BILL WILL BE REFLECTIVE OF
THAT. BYE SO IF THE BILL
WHATEVER AMENDMENTS ARE
REFLECTED ON THURSDAY THERE WILL
BE AN AMENDED ANALYSIS TO
REFLECT THOSE AMENDMENTS. OKAY
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS SIGNAL THE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX TWENTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. OUR FINAL
BILL THE DAY IS S. B. SIX TWO
TWO BY SENATOR ROTH ON STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID. THIS IS A SPENT
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE'LL MOVE
RIGHT PUBLIC TESTIMONY IS THERE
ANYONE. IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF SIXTY TWO SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
MODERATOR IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
TWO TWO. FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX TWO TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THE TIME WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE ANYONE
OPPOSED IN THIS ROOM JUST BE SIX
TO SING NOW AND RUSHED TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB SIX
TWO TWO. M. FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX TWO TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THE
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN
OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT WE TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION ON SB SIX
TWO TO SIGNAL QUESTIONS OUR
HANDS GO UP FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB SIX TWO
TWO WILL GO TO THE FENCE WE HAVE
ONE ITEM ON CALL WHICH IS SB SIX
THREE TO THE CLAIMS BILL.
SENATOR BATES- SO MISTER CONSULT
WE'RE GONNA LIFT THE CALL ON A
FIFTY SIX THREE TWO. SENATE BILL
SIX THIRTY TO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
BATES ARE NOT VOTING. SENATOR
JONES. FIVE OUT THE BILL IS OUT
WITH FIVE VOTES TO WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE ON THAT AND WE WILL GO
TO THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY- IF YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE THEM.
IN OUR OFFICIAL HEARINGS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE REFERRED ONE
BILL TO THE SENATE FLOOR AND THE
REST OF GONE ON TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE AND SO WITH THAT THIS
COMMITTEE. IS ADJOURNED.